president biden is trying to clarify his
comments expressing concern about monkey
pox he says he does not see the need to
institute strict quarantine measures and
that the virus does not compare with
covet 19.
we've had this
monkey parks for the larger numbers in
the past number one
number two we have vaccines to care for
to take care of it
number three
there is
thus far there doesn't seem to be
a need for any kind of extra
extra effort beyond what's going on
so let's bring an expert dr amos adalja
a senior scholar johns hopkins center
for health security uh doctor thanks for
being here where do you see the threat
from monkey pox looking at the cases
we're we're seeing around the country
and around the world
the monkey box is not a threat to the
general public this is something we've
dealt with before what's interesting
about this outbreak that's occurring now
is it's transmitting person to person
with people who haven't been to any of
the endemic areas in africa haven't had
contact with the animals so we've got
some epidemiological work to do to help
this
healthy outbreak it's not something that
has pandemic potential or should be
thought of anything like covet 19
but but it is something that we need to
take corrective action we need to use
the vaccine and figure out how people
are getting infected and stop those
links in transmission yeah the who is
according to the associated press says a
leading adviser to the world health
organization described the unprecedented
outbreak of monkey box in developed
countries as a random event that might
be explained by sexual behavior at two
recent raves in europe
because of what we've seen in covid uh
whenever there is some the next thing
people get fearful but they should not
be fearful of this next thing is that
what you're saying right this is
something that seems to have gotten into
sexual networks and has been able to
spread the way that it hasn't in the
past and
this is something as we've heard about
before we had a major outbreak in 2003
related to animals we have tools like
the smallpox vaccine which can be
deployed on the contacts of cases so
this isn't something that i see
spreading
wide and far it's going we're going to
see more cases more states are going to
have cases that's expected but it is
something that can be contained and that
we know how to deal with
and
children should be careful right if if
you
what if you have it if you get it
what should people do obviously go to
the doctor go to the hospital what
you should seek medical help you should
then isolate yourself and notify your
contacts that you might have monkey box
we know that people are contagious for
for several sometimes several weeks with
monkey pucks because of all the skin
lesions you have to wait till they heal
so you don't want to be around people
when you have those leeches that's why
it's kind of the bread and butter public
health that needs to be put into place
contact tracing and then vaccination of
context and there's a tendency to view
every every pandemic or every outbreak
or every infectious disease emergency
through the light of covenant 19 or
through the lens of copper 19 and that's
not correct because these are different
biological viruses with different
characteristics and have very different
response measures
dr adelger that's what we wanted to have
you on some straight talk we appreciate
your time
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else